hi I'm Eric Voss and Captain Marvel
released new footage with arguably the
most critical detail that connects this
movie to the events of Avengers infinity
war and Avengers endgame Nick Fury's
pager from the infinity war post credits
scene let's check out this footage the
communicator page the books that are in
a pasta dignities wait what oh crap it's
in Russian don't worry I got you covered
I'm gonna translate this Russian promo
spot for you guys and explain what this
tells us about how Captain Marvel could
come into play in a ventures endgame
spoiler warning in case I revealed too
much in Berlin okay before we get to
that pager there's actually an earlier
news shot with Captain Marvel in this
phone booth we saw set foot of this
before but a few things have changed for
one those 90s rock to vote posters don't
appear in this one it's just a wall of
wooden planks this might be because Rock
the Vote is an American political
reference and in Russia they don't rock
the boat so much as line up and cold
outside neutral-colored building and
votes and predetermined election for
strongman leader while he rocks foolish
American election yeah shut up the
Russians ain't watching there's no way
their sensors will let them see this and
my phone just got tapped more
importantly look at what Captain Marvel
has done here she appears to have
dismantled this payphone and she's using
the hardware to connect to her Buzz
Lightyear gauntlet tech producing this
qui holo projection out of her hand
very cool maybe she's using the phone's
wiring to hack into the other end of
this phone call and she's displaying her
monitor as a hologram or maybe she's
using this to communicate with the Kree
the idea that Carol might know how to
engineer human communication technology
despite having no memory of Earth and
everything in her mind being implanted
there by the Kree this could present
some interesting applications for
example is human tech secretly based on
alien critic like primitive versions of
their advanced tech that they could have
passed on to us is Carol using this
phone as a makeshift 90s dial-up
internet modem but speaking of primitive
nineties communication technology this
brings us to Nick Fury's pager we see
him right with target and clip it to his
belt and then there's this exchange at
the communicator pager the books they're
only postulating apiece me
wage it nah now I've been watching a lot
of the Americans on FX so I think I got
this okay this translates to Carol
asking is it a communicator and fury
responds last time I trusted someone I
lost enough man make your really hung up
on that I'm sorry I just had to know if
URI actually responds this is a pager
new model and then there's another clip
in Russian Steve a JIT nah this one you
could probably get from context Carol
says hey fury says what she says give me
the pager and he says take it so this
could mean that the pager in this movie
isn't the exact same pager that we saw
Nick Fury used in the infinity war
post-credit scene this one could be one
that he uses in the 90s but then hands
off to Carol in this scene maybe because
he keeps using it the way we're glued to
our smart phones which would be kind of
funny or it keeps beeping during
inopportune moments while he and Carol
are on a stealth mission
so maybe Carolyn said keeping this pager
and then fury gets a new one at the end
of Captain Marvel so that he can page
her if slash win he ever needs her help
that might explain why Fury's pager an
Infinity Ward looks a little more souped
up and why this screen can display in
color whereas very screening this
trailer is only green and black Carol
now possessing this pager could mean
that Captain Marvel ends with she and
fury getting abruptly separated and
maybe she never got a chance to return
the pager Mike maybe some cliffhanger
where Captain Marvel just disappears and
fury gets a new pager and has actually
reached out to her periodically over the
years hoping that she'll reply and she
never has which would explain her
absence but then her sigil appearing in
that last frame and infinity war means
that this time things are finally bad
enough for her to join the fight however
the circumstances of Carolyn Fury's
setting up this whole pager link and a
plane out we're starting to understand
the reason Captain Marvel is being set
in the 1990s there's just something
about old-school pre widely available
wireless internet communication
technology that will play a major role
in this movie perhaps it will be
revealed that the Kree are responsible
for humans communication strides and if
the Kree end up being less noble and
heroic than we think they are as I
theorized in other videos that would
compromise all of Earth's traditional
communication network making it
difficult for Carol Danvers to disappear
from them if she wants to and maybe
these stay in - they are
but soon to be obsolete pagers are the
only way Carolyn fury can stay in touch
off the grid without being monitored
this would actually mirror the
old-school flip phones at cap and Stark
used after Civil War and in the
beginning of infinity war to contact
each other without the government
tracing the call or maybe just the Gaz
cap is an old man who thinks smartphones
are witchcraft comment down below with
your thoughts on all of this stuff and
follow me on twitter and instagram at a
vas follow new rockstars on twitter and
subscribe to this channel and to our
podcasts just search new rockstars
wherever you listen to podcasts thank
you for watching and I'm sorry
wait are you speaking Russian I'm sorry
for what I said
[Music]